an epinet is a diagram it's a diagram
that lets me figure out and map and keep
track of what you're thinking what
you're thinking I'm thinking what other
people in the room think about what I'm
thinking and what each things about what
every other person in the room is
thinking that sounds like a lot and
that's why you need a diagram and it's a
little bit different than your
traditional social network diagram in
that you don't have only people that are
connected by edges and lines you also
have various beliefs so if I think that
you think that today it is Friday then
there's going to be an arch that takes
us from me to you to the proposition
today is Friday if I think that you
think that I think that today is Friday
there's an arch that takes me from me to
you back to me and back to the
proposition today is Friday why is this
very helpful in the context of something
like a meeting or a gathering of any
kind or an email exchange when we have a
meeting there are a lot of unspoken
suppositions and a lot of attributions
that I make I think about what other
people think and what they think I think
and sometimes I have conversations with
somebody that are meant to be
dramaturgical so they're meant to be a
piece of theater that we play out for
the benefit of other people in the
audience so I might try to persuade you
that it's a good thing for you to put
your hat in the ring for a presidential
race or the cane or race not because I
think that's a good thing but because I
think somebody else thinks that I don't
think that's a good thing
I want to persuade that person that in
fact I think highly of you
so what I've done in that case is I've
used the topology of the beliefs that
various people have and the beliefs that
they have about other people's belief in
the room to create a situation so you
can think of an epinet first of all as a
diagram but then you can also think
about it as a design tool and it's a
tool for the design of human
interactions in contexts that are
high-stakes interpersonal
the acute if you will because that's
where we spend a lot of time obsessing
about what everybody thinks and what
everybody thinks we think and
complicated even the very simple
structures that I was telling you about
have a very complex interactive belief
hierarchy there are things that I
believe that you don't know about there
are things that you believe that I don't
know about
there are conjectures that you have
about what I think which I am oblivious
self because I can't even imagine some
of them and there are things that I can
conjecture about you which you may be
oblivious of and it's very important to
not necessarily to obsess and to be
doomed to become neurotic about this but
it's important to be precise and it is
valuable to be precise and that is what
a lot of the EPI Nets work that we've
done tends to show that more greater
precision greater depth so if I think
more carefully about what you think and
what you think I think and what you
think I think you think then it makes me
more likely to respond to your concerns
it makes me more likely to address
problems issues and complaints that you
might have it makes us more likely to be
able to coordinate our actions
successfully it makes us more able to Co
mobilize in order to do something that's
important to both of us and that comes
from greater precision it doesn't come
necessarily from a catch-all Theory like
let's say game theory or interactive
epistemology that go bonkers in terms of
the formalism but they don't focus on
the precise structure of the beliefs as
they occur in a human group interacting
in
you